welcome to the second half of simply
learns Python tutorial
my name is Richard Kirchner with the
simply learned team that's WW simply
learn comm get certified get ahead we're
going to take on seven parts or seven
code challenges that you can do to take
all the basics we've covered so far in
Python and see how to apply them and
we'll start with part one part one we
want to go ahead and see if we can print
the number of occurrences of each
character in a string and this would be
a good time to pause the video so you
can actually try to solve it on your own
before we go ahead and give you the
solution we came up with now remember
there's always multiple solutions to any
of these challenges so if you come up
with a different one that's great
you know it just means you're thinking
on there the first thing you want to do
is we want to go ahead and get an input
so we want to go ahead and pull up an
input for our word that we're gonna type
in and then we're looking for the number
of characters in a string so we need
some way to track it and we have we call
a dictionary now if you remember we
briefly touched upon the dictionary a
dictionary is denoted with two brackets
and it comes in the form of a key so
you'll have your key code and then that
key code is set to a value so the value
can change the key code cannot and if we
had Reckitt surround this could initiate
it if you already know your initial keys
and values with something that looks
like this and we can also here's our D
assign 'm as we go and so we'd have our
key and then this would equal our value
and what's nice about these two setups
is that we have a key code which could
represent our characters and then we
have the value which is going to
represent the count hopefully you
remember MapReduce we're thinking map
and reduce this is such a common
question that comes up in map and reduce
so we're going to map all our characters
out and then count them and reduce that
to in a huge MapReduce program you would
actually do each document and how to
have a summation and then that would be
sent and brought together and then
reduced to just a single representation
of it so we're doing kind of the end
part where we're just reducing this word
so here we have our dictionary and then
we want to go ahead and do a for I loop
for I and s so our input is s
and this will iterate over each
character in the string
the next thing we want to know is do we
already have D in our dictionary in this
case we're looking at each of our I so
if I and D so if it's already in there
then we can simply do this we can simply
do D of I and then you can do the plus
equals and then of course we're just
adding one to X or incrementing it by
one now if it doesn't exist in the
dictionary and you try to do that you'll
get an error so you know key value there
so now we have to do a thing where if I
is not in D we do simply D of I and we
initialize it with one keep it simple
and then finally we've got a lot of
different things we can just print D and
if I run this let's go ahead and take
that and run it comes up says enter a
string and we'll do hello I'll hit enter
and you'll see I have H capital H equals
1 lowercase e equals 1 l equals 2
there's two L's and oels one you can
also if you're trying to look at it a
little bit clearer you could do for ki
and D we could do something like this
print D of key and you gotta remember
you it doesn't actually print the key
unless you tell it to so here's the key
and the d of key so I can also do it
this way so you can pick another a
better word on here you actually do a
full phrase in here so welcome to Python
and hit enter and you'll see that we
have W 1 e has 2 L has 1 C 103 M 1
there's 2 spaces
T is 2 P is 1 Y is 1 H and so on so this
is a very simple set of loops but it
covers a lot of interesting key points
that you'll use throughout any kind of
big data or map and reduce program so
let's move to part 2 or challenge to let
me just clear my palate so we have a
nice palette and what we're gonna do for
part 2 is we're going to insert an
element at the case position of a list
and again you know pause it if you need
to let's go ahead and create our list
and in this case we're gonna do just a
standard list we'll do some mixed
elements we'll have like 23 it looks
like they sent me an example the list
let me just grab that so let's do 23 hey
Oh 89 Python so we have a nice list
there with 1 2 3 4 5 objects or 0
through 4 if you're thinking indexing
and let's go ahead and do this we'll
print this
print the original list comma list and
then we need our input in equals input
and I guess we need to put where we're
going to enter it at so it says input
and let's do enter on index between they
have let's see we can just a couple
different ways but let's say we do zero
which we put it at the beginning and
then at the end how would you get to
know the end well we could do this plus
string of length in this case length of
list and remember we don't want it to
type in the action well I can say could
type in the actual end so it could be
zero or it could be the very end of the
list so this end should give us a nice
input and then let's have an object or
we'll just call it K I'll actually just
put this above sometimes it's nice to
put these in a different order k equals
input let's go ahead and have it enter
an element and so this will
automatically be a string that we enter
here I'm gonna go ahead and just add a
space there so it stays on the same line
if you have a larger screen this might
look better if it goes down a line but
in this case I want to go ahead and just
keep that in the same line and we'll do
this on here I'll do plus and add a
space and this will be our element in
and K for the actual integer and we want
to make sure this days is an integer so
let's go ahead and take this whole thing
and add integer at the beginning it's
for our index integer at the end so now
we have our input we're gonna add an
element in this case it's going to
always be a string unless we want to try
to convert it and then we're gonna enter
in where it's going to go and so how do
we get there how do we put that in that
list and so there is actually a number
of ways you can actually do an insert
but let's say we don't have the list
insert command make a little hard on us
let's go ahead and do this let's go
ahead and do a list append and we're
going to append this case K that's
entity we entered in here so if we
pretend not to do the list insert and we
have the append we can append our value
on to the end of our list and what we're
gonna do and again there's like so many
different solutions for this I mean if I
was just doing an insert into my list I
would just do an insert but let's say
sometimes you have to do other than
finding out the spot on there you might
be comparing the values or doing
something else going on so we can do is
we can go for I and range 0
, links of list so we're gonna create an
integer that comes in here and just
starts at the zero index so I friend X
and just pages through all of our
objects in the list and we want to know
is if I is greater than and we had our K
value now if you did like I did up here
zero you could also do K value equals
one so this gets a little tricky on your
input if you're talking about your end
client do they notice dart zero as play
zero or do they start with place one so
that might change your coding and how
you put this together
those are things you'd want to think
about now we're gonna do temp equals
list of I so we go ahead and we look at
our list and we say okay I'm going to
pull this object off I'll create a temp
here list of I equals in and we're going
to swap in our n value and then we'll do
in equals temp so let's take a look at
this I have if I is greater than K and
since we're starting with zero we'll go
do I is greater than or equal to K
that's just because we're starting with
a zero instead of one and we take we go
ahead and create a temp variable that
goes to that pointer list of I then
equals n that's our last element in this
case is the one we entered and then we
set N equal to temp so we'd take this
and we take whatever's in that position
we put it in temp and then we just go
all the way through and what happens is
it will just keep replacing that value
all the way to the end and let's go
ahead and see what that looks like
before we do this I guess we have to
print out an answer so we'll come down
here we'll go print and our updated list
comma and this is just list let's go
ahead and run this and we'll toe down
here and let's enter in hello and I
always like to do the extreme so we have
0 and 5 so let's go into 0 and enter and
we have our list which is original 23
all the way to Python and now it says
hello and puts a right at the beginning
if you're gonna do that you should also
test out the end of the list so what
happens if I put in 5 and it comes up
and you see it puts hello at the end
what happens if we put in 4 double check
here we go 4 and it comes up on place
number 4 and I'll do one more test on
this just because I really don't like
things going out the door unless I know
they work and we'll put in one and
you'll see here 0 1 2 3 and so on and
there
our hello and you can see here we had a
nice setup on that we have our input we
just go through it's really important to
note that we're iterating through each
value and we're seeing if something
important is going to need to change
that value this could be almost anything
this could be that you need to alter not
only insert the value but maybe
increment everything past it with plus
one or something there's all kinds of
things that can come up the weird logic
that you wouldn't think of until you
start messing with it challenge or part
three check if the substring is present
in a string without using the find
method I remember back in the 90s this
was central to all of your programming
was to do all these little things now
the course they have fine built into the
functionality so string we need ever
input we're gonna input a string and
we're gonna input a substring and we'll
call them st for string and sub for sub
string and i'm gonna jump ahead a little
bit here and then come back because we
want to look at something this to count
equals zero and then we're gonna do our
loop for I in range zero we want to
start with position zero and then we
want to go to what that's where the
question comes in well we could do the
links of the string now there's a
problem with this and that is that the
substring might be five letters long so
if I go to the length of the string I'm
actually comparing the substring to
something that isn't even there so I'm
going past the end of the string that's
not really worth doing so how do we
figure out that number well we can do L
equals length of our substring so now we
have a value for how long the substring
is and we simply take the zero to length
of string minus L and then we add want
to add one on there so remember that
this links it goes exactly to that
length without including it so we have
to add the plus one in there to include
the very end of that so 0 to the length
of the string so the next question is
how do we know we have it well if or our
sub string equals string and we want to
start from position I and we want to go
to I plus L the length of the substring
so if they're equal we'll print
count plus equals 1 our increment of 1
and we'll do print substring here's our
placeholder s for a string found at
position and then here's our placeholder
for a number or D in this case and we'll
go ahead and give it just a space off of
here or no that's fine we don't need a
space on that and then we have our amber
sign a percent sign and our tuple so
here's our two pole we want sub come I
so they'll put that right in there this
will tell us that it's in there each
time it finds a substring we're counting
it
then we print it out that it's part of
it a little redundant because it'll just
print out the same thing over and over
again and then we can do if count equals
zero we can print substring not found
and of course an else statement else
print will do substring substring here's
our place marker again s found another
placeholder d times and then we can if
you're gonna do your place holders of
course you have to do your tuple at the
end and we have our sub comma in this
case count so let's see what that looks
like when it runs before we do that
let's just walk through it so let's take
a walk through what we just did so we
have four I equals range we had to kind
of fiddle a little bit with the length
to make sure we got all the way to the
end but we didn't go past it for finding
our sub in the range of the string
simple if statement says hey it's here
count plus equals one let's go ahead and
print our substring found this will be
very repetitive so don't you really know
wouldn't normally put this in here just
to keep printing it and then it says if
count equals zero we found none print
substring not found and else substring S
found d times with our count so let's go
ahead and run this and here it goes
enter our string welcome to simply learn
I'm gonna hit enter and we're gonna look
for the let's go to and it gave me an
error so what happened here and I of
course get an error hopefully you caught
this error when I was putting it
together this should be a colon not a
comma this is a straight list so that's
why you gotta remember what rate you're
working in and it does happen and we'll
go ahead and run this again and we'll do
welcome to simply learn type in our to
and it comes up and says substring to
found one times substring found at
position eight so now we know a position
sat and we also have how many times it
was found and since I was just talking
about numpy arrays let's do challenge or
part four find the index for the nth
repetition of a number and a numpy array
so let's go ahead and import our numpy
as in P you'll see that very standard
and I went ahead and created an array or
team in the back did so we are gonna go
and create our variable a are set to a
numpy array and it's just 1 2 4 123 1 2
3 4 so it's kind of a random set of
numbers on here and let's see how we can
build this and at this point you should
be trying to think about how to do it
yourself and let's go ahead and I'll
just paste this in here we're gonna
print the original array just so you can
double check it in our output and we're
going to do our input num equals an
integer and then give a value for the
number for your input so we'll have our
num we're gonna look for and let's do
this if num in our so the first thing we
want to know is even as in there there's
always a chance you might not even have
that number in there initiating or doing
initial case so if we're looking for
kind of the base case of do we want to
even do anything if it's not in there so
if number in a our first thing you want
to do is check otherwise it's not worth
processing and then let's do this so we
want to ask the question what is the
index for the nth repetition so we got
to find out what repetition the user
wants and we'll go ahead and create
another input in give a value for n
which is our repetition or repeat so
give a value for n or the repeat on here
now at this point there's so many
different ways to solve this we could
iterate through but we're going to
create and you'll hear the term mask let
me just type that out for you or you're
masking something masking means that we
create a series of values in this case
we're going to create a bunch of ones
I'm going to say it equals NP so here's
a numpy array where our input array
equals our number so this is going to
return a numpy array of either ones or
zeros then we can actually test it and
see what's in there now there's other
ways we could just iterate through the
numpy array usually when you're working
with numpy arrays you try not to iterate
across them the whole purpose of the
numpy array is to let it leverage the
back end code so you're not wasting as
much resources
and you know what let's go ahead and
print one out just so you can see what
that looks like what this masking does
so NP where our equals number let's go
ahead and run that and here's our setup
let's do enter in the number one and
value for in repeat doesn't really
matter cuz we're not doing anything with
it yet we'll put in three and if you
look at the output of this mask we've
created its setup and returns an array
and the array is 0 3 5 9 15 18 it
returns all the positions of our number
in the array so here's NP where our
equals number and then we just called it
1 if you print one out you can see we
just get a nice list of indexes and this
is really useful to us let's go back in
here and then we can very simply on the
indexes do if we have our n we'll do
less than or equal to the length of our
1 and remember this is a tuple coming in
this array so we have the first part is
the actual indexes and the second part
is our d type so we really want to do
the 1 of 0 and this is important if you
haven't worked with numpy arrays or even
if you work with them a lot sometimes
you just do a quick printout to find out
what it is you're looking at so you can
remember the format on there and we'll
do this if it's less than or equal to
the length of one a 0 then we can simply
print 1 over 0 position and then on here
we want to do since that's also itself
as array we want to do the lay n minus 1
remember we start with 0 so if we want
to find out how many is in there or you
know what the position it is we're
counting 1 2 3 but the array is 0 1 2 so
we have to put the N minus 1 in there
and of course if we don't find it we'll
do an else statement and we'll print
there art and then we'll go ahead and
put down a placeholder just we can keep
track of it
currencies of one just keep it simple
this time and then finally we'll go back
here and you had our original if number
in the are of course have an else print
that it's not in there oh let's go ahead
and run that and we have our list down
here let me move this thing back up so
we can see what the run looks like we'll
look for let's look for a 1 and we
wanted to repeat them forth and it
returns it in position 9 there we go and
if we
appear and entered in list entry and
just a random number I don't see the
number 33 so we'll put 33 in there 33
not in the array so it doesn't even go
through because we put that initial test
right at the beginning that says hey if
it's not in here don't even bother and
then we went through and counted them
now you probably found your own solution
very central to our solution was the
where statement where it's going to map
out the indexes of this occurrence where
our equals number and this is part of
masking there's all kinds of ways to
mask your data usually you mask the
whole array across something we need to
talk about masking in this case we're
just returning a simple array where it
lists the indexes let's go ahead and
clean our screen here for part 5
generate a dictionary that contains
pairs such as I comma I times I where I
integer is between 1 and an entered
value sometimes I'll break these up if
I'm for readability so we'll do that
there we go so we're gonna generate a
dictionary that's the first thing we
need to do and we need a value entered
so let's go ahead and do both of those
and there's a couple ways to generate a
dictionary earlier we did the two
squiggly brackets you can also just do D
equals dictionary if I run this you'll
see that it works and that's for a
number go ahead and for the processes I
could have easily just have also done
this with a double brackets that's the
same thing so if you see something
dictionary you can also these are
equivalent statements d equals brackets
and D equals dictionary or the
dictionary object and will do for I and
range one n plus one so there's a number
we entered and in our dictionary we're
gonna do D of AI
there's our key equals and our value I
times I and you could have also done
since this is just squaring it we could
have also done squared that's the same
thing as I times I I squared we'll go
ahead and do I times I and then well
simply because you want to see what your
end is is print D and let's go ahead and
run this and we'll shift this up just a
little bit it says enter a number we'll
enter 3 and if I run that or if I hit
enter on there I get 1 1 so 1 squared is
1 2 squared is 4 3 squared is 9
and you could go on as far as you wanted
on there I couldn't earn a significant
ly larger number but it goes up to
whatever my range is on that this is
again an example of dictionary how to
build a dictionary in simple ways on
there alright let's go ahead and clear
our screen for part 6 write a program
which takes two digits XY as input and
generates a matrix the element value in
the eighth row and the J's column of the
array should be I times J there's a lot
of ways to do this we're going to do
this as a list of lists my first thought
though would be to put this in numpy
because numpy can do this very are
there's a lot of automated ways to do
this in numpy but let's go ahead and
look at the backend how would you do
this into a regular list
so before we start solving this problem
how do we get our data we have two
inputs what if I wanted to have just one
input where I have you enter X comma Y
what would that look like
take out the space there except could
cause an issue well there's a couple
ways to do this one is if we want to
generate an XY this member is going to
return a tuple for whatever I do we
could do something like this so on here
we're entering a string with two
integers how do we convert those well we
can do integer X for X in string dot
split this is a really kind of a fun
shorthand for Python for iterating
through our setup so what we got here is
we're gonna first of all split our
string so here's our string it comes in
with 2 comma 3 and then we take and we
split it by the comma and for each
entity in that split we want to return
the integer of that entity in this case
we've labeled it X and so this should go
through and do XY and it should return
an X integer and a Y in it jur and let's
just see what that looks like maybe just
go ahead and print X comma Y now let's
go ahead and run that and here our XY is
we go 3 comma 2 hit enter and it enters
3 comma 2 now if you're putting out a
full package what happens if you have
somebody who's overzealous and does
something like this
345 3 enter we're gonna get a unpacked -
many values so this returned this huge
list of
numbers I've typed in and gave me an
error so you gotta remember that when
you're doing these different inputs you
might sort it out and just look for the
first two of them there's all kinds of
different ways to do this so now we have
our X Y if you went ahead and just did
the inter X and enter Y that's okay
and we want to generate a list so our
list then we're gonna put together it's
going to be and again we're doing some
nested stuff here which is a lot of fun
we're going to create a two by two
matrix and so we're going to have 4 0
for column and range Y and for row and
range X so what we're doing here is this
is going to put a 0 in each of these in
here and then this is simply column is
our for column column is nothing more
than a place holder I could have done
for C in range Y same thing with row
that's because it has to have a value
this shows up here and we're just gonna
fill everything with 0 and let's go
ahead and print this print list we run
this and you'll see here's our inner XY
we'll do 3 comma 3 and we end up with 0
0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 here's our two
iterations done the Python Ian way it's
going to return you know the square
brackets on the end so it's returning an
array and for the first one we're gonna
put 0 for column in range of Y and then
we're gonna repeat that again for row
and range of X instead of 0 we can
simply do this I can do column times row
and if we run this we'll see here's our
XY let's do 3 comma 3 again that way
it's not too big on there
and we end up with 0 0 0 0 1 2 0 2 4 and
we might get a little fancy in this and
do oh you know what let's do it this way
import numpy as in P and then maybe
we'll do numpy array equals NP dot array
of and then we'll enter in our list that
we created and then let's print in PA
remember that when I see here matrix I
automatically go right in for the numpy
array so we'll enter our 3 comma 3 and
you can see here that numpy is designed
for doing matrixes and so we have 0
times 0 0 times 1 0 times 2
1 times 0 1 times 1 1 times 2 and so on
so we create a nice little matrix of I 2
J and then we put it into numpy just
because we can and not be has such a
nicer format on there so let's go ahead
and clear our palette let's move on to
part 7 and in part 7 we're gonna find
the h CF of a 2 numbers using recursion
and h CF if you if you don't know what h
CF is its highest common factor or
denominator of two numbers using
recursion I couldn't remember it I had
to look that up so let's do a definition
we'll create our little function h CF
and what comes into there is going to be
x and y and what I want to know is we
want the highest one so we'll do if
first of all Y is not equal to 0 if it's
equal to 0 you you don't want to divide
it anything because they'll give you an
error anything divided by 0 and let's
take that and we're going to just return
HC f of Y comma X and here's a remainder
of Y so H CF y of X so remainder of Y so
we're looking for this is just the
remainder so we turn the remainder on
here on this else we want to return X
and so we wouldn't need our input on
this before we go any further so let's
grab a input and we'll do the same kind
of input we did before we're entering x
and y and or two positive integers and
this is just from a previous example so
we'll just go ahead and grab the integer
X for X and in this case it's not string
keep it this string on there St and have
our two integers here from before keep
it simple and then let's just go ahead
and combine it all into one line Python
yin way if you can put it into one easy
to read line then you should do so so
we're gonna print h c FF of placeholder
D and placeholder D is also is
placeholder D and this is our X or Y and
then we're going to just print out the
return value of our HC f of X Y let's go
ahead and run this we're gonna enter in
two positive numbers let's go 12 and 18
and so the HC f of 12 and 18 is 6 that
would be our most common denominator
let's go ahead and clear out part 7 and
then bonus we are gonna throw
part eight quicksort so we have a bonus
round heart eight
quicksort and we're going to positive
list of integers so we're going to do a
quick sort on positive list of integers
on here there's like so many different
ways to do different sorting zhan this
one of the ways to do it is to look at a
list and then partition that list and
then you go through that partition and
you sort it and then you sort of smaller
lists and smaller lists and so on and so
on so that's what we're going to do on
this one before we start though we do
need to go ahead and grab our data and
set that up and so you can do it a
number of different ways we can do comma
separated we're going to switch it up a
little bit on this one because it's just
fun to try different things and we're
gonna do enter in n number of objects in
the list we're gonna enter each of those
values into our array and our array
we're just going to input an integer of
them print the original list this should
be pretty familiar because we've done so
many inputs in this lesson in the last
lesson all we're doing on this one is
we're just appending the input here and
how many inputs it'll go down the list
and if we go ahead and just run this
first piece of code real quick number of
objects in the input we'll do three
values of the objects we'll do three two
five and you can see here's our original
series three to five pretty basic and
straightforward and because for me space
is a commodity as far as our output and
this green I have for your catching you
in whichever in there we'll just put it
on one line will say original list so
the first thing we want to do is if
we're going to do partitions let's
create a module for partitioning out our
data and so we'll start with a simple
definition procedure and we'll call it
partition and we want to take our list
that it's sent we want a low value a
high value and what we're gonna do with
this is we're going to create I equals
low minus one so remember this is an
index and we actually started with zero
so now we're actually one less than the
index if we're initiating this with zero
on one end and the maximum on the high
end and we'll call it pivot and the
pivot it's going to be a value
set that list equal to our list of our
high index so remember high lower
indexes I is an index pimmit is a value
that's the actual value in this position
of whatever we send it so we're going to
send it to pointers low and high and
we're gonna send it the list and when we
initiate this we usually will set it up
as first entity which is index of zero
for low and then for a high will have
the highest index on there then we need
to go ahead and do 4j in range low comma
high so we're gonna go through all the
different values in there and if list of
j is less than or equal to pivot then I
equals I plus 1 but we like to do with
the Python way so plus equals 1 now
remember we subtracted 1 up here so this
is 1 less than whatever index we sent it
which if we start with 0 would be minus
1 and this brings it back up to 0 so
this is why we put this in here at the
top part actually gonna stop here just
for a second because sorting is one of
the most basic things it's very
confusing as to why the sorting is so
difficult and one of the reasons it's so
difficult is because if I have the
numbers 3 2 1 there's so many different
ways to sort this one I could take and
look at these two numbers and if this
value is higher than this one I could
swap them which would then give me 2
comma 3 comma 1 and then I can look at
these two numbers and if there's bigger
than I can do swap them and then I get 2
comma 1 comma 3 and then I got to start
over because now the 2 and the 1 aren't
in order and so you can see with the
lengthy list whatever I do
starts running into factorials in
factorial runs and there's no real easy
way around this because if I put a
reverse list 3 2 1 it's going to
maximize how many runs it takes and so
finding different ways to sort the data
depending on what you're doing can be
really confusing so understanding just
what's going on with this particular
sort we're doing helps to start
understanding where this problem occurs
and certainly there's tools out there to
sort it for you which are already
maximized sometimes you have to sort on
values that aren't you know the value
you're sorting on might be different it
might be
instead of sorting on J it might be the
remainder of J divided by something or
it might be the percentage of J over
another column so being able to sort
these things is important and knowing
how this works the logic behind it is
more important than the actual coding at
this point so we get in here we go I
equals I plus 1 to remember that I put
this case we did it somehow reverted
there i plus equals 1 and then we're
going to do list of I comma list J
equals list J comma list of I and this
is just a cool Python way of swapping
values you can see here we have J I
becomes IJ so we're literally we're
swapping the values up here as we go
through this partition on right here and
this works on our counting because we
have I which right off the bat is set to
0 we have high which is not the end
value but one less than the in value so
our range of J is going from 0 to not
quite the last digit and our eye is
going from we've netted the plus 1 and
then it goes to the end here so we have
our list of our list of J and we swap
them out depending on if listed J is
greater than pivot and we can also do
something like this here's our pivot
we'll just take our pivot out up here so
here we have our list of high is going
to be our pivot number that we're
switching around and we're just
iterating it through and swapping values
and then finally we'll go ahead and run
this one more time list of I plus 1 list
of high equals list of high common list
of I plus 1 so one last swamp at the end
now if you're looking at I equals low
minus 1 let's do this this is kind of
fun to do clean up our code a little bit
I'm incrementing it right here why I
don't know I can increment it right
afterwards and it has the same result of
taking the minus 1 off of here and just
adding it after I need it and this then
carries down to here where I have I plus
1 well I'm adding it at the end so I
don't need to add it again and we
simplify it down to y equals low
following our eyes through there we have
list of vilest of J listed J listed by
swapping here's our increment and then
our final swap at the end and what we
want to go ahead and do is we just want
to return I plus 1 and so for
have our partition set up this way we're
returning the I plus one or in this case
just I we one return I carried it down
forgot to carry it down there
we've taken our list we've swapped it
around because we're passing the list
we're passing the actual list not just a
pointer to it and then we got to return
the I so we know what we did and so if
you remember down there when I did that
example the first time through we swap
it around and then it comes up and says
oh okay we've already swapped the
high-value all the way up to the right
hand side then we have to start over so
we'll go ahead and call this quick sort
and the quick sort it's going to take
the list a low and a high just like we
did for our partition and what we want
to do that is if lo is less than high
then we want to go ahead and partition
the index we fix my tabs there we go so
PT is a value from the partition that's
coming back that's what's this I
returned and so we will go ahead and
partition our list and we have our low
and high value going in there if we're
going to partition our list once we get
the PT back we can go ahead and do a
quick sort on the same list low comma PT
minus one so it goes through the list it
moves the highest value to the end and
then we want to take that PT it returns
and we want to subtract one because we
know where the high point is so now we
have a shorter list to go through yeah
we sort it from the other end to it
we'll do a quick sort and we'll do our
list comma PT plus 1 comma high so we're
coming out from the other end
so we're basically sorting the list
going both directions on here so this is
our sort on this one we've now sorted
our list so we need to go ahead and call
that and we can simply call that let's
see oh we can print out the list let's
do this let's go print there's our
original list sorted list we'll put a
little placeholder or you know what we
won't put a placeholder there we'll just
put a comma in and of course it probably
helps to actually return the list so
we'll go up here and do a return list
that we've nicely sorted on here
and we'll come down here to this part
and do a quick sort and we have our list
that we put in we're going to start with
0 for initiating it and then we have our
high value which is simply the length of
the list because that points to
actually link to the list - one that's
going to point to the last index and
then real quick before I run this let's
do some quick cleanup here the original
list and then we want to create a second
list which equals the original and then
we're going to print our sorted list and
we're going to send it this information
for our quicksort so let's go and see
what that looks like let's go ahead and
run this and we're going to enter our
number of values we'll just do 3 and
we're going to enter in 3 2 1 let's open
this up so we can see what's going on
down here so here's our original list 3
2 1 and you can see it's nicely sorted 1
2 3 and if I was testing this out I
would enter in 1 2 3 to see what
happened I would enter in 2 3 1
just some quick changes to make sure
it's sorting correctly in fact let's go
ahead and do that real quick let's go
ahead and or another list I'll do it for
and I'll do 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 sorts out is
1 2 3 4 and I actually know from doing
these so many times that that's more
than enough on these but just in case
let's go to 1 3 4 & 1 2 3 4 there we go
quicksort for our list so that wraps it
up thank you for joining us today for
python part 2 where we covered not only
seven but bonus eight different parts we
went in there and we looked at
everything from basically finding the
elements in what position on a list the
number of occurrence of characters to
dictionary use and key codes and finally
a quick sort at the end again thank you
for joining us my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learned team
that's WW simply learn comm get
certified get ahead feel free to comment
below on the YouTube video as we do have
moderators who monitor the questions and
post down there or visit us at our
website and we'll be happy to help you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here